about five years ago I caught wind that
Sergey Brin
was funding the construction of a secret
Airship right here at NASA Ames in
Mountain View
I saw some pictures of this early
Airship it got kind of obsessed with it
Sergey didn't want to talk about his
Airship but over the last couple years I
managed to ingratiate myself with the
guy who's bringing Sergey brin's Airship
to life
and today I'm going to take you guys in
to see this thing being made
[Music]
I'm Alan Weston and I'm the CEO of LTA
and I'm the first person to work on this
project we've got this beauty behind us
give us give us the basics this is
Pathfinder one this is 122 meters long
has about 28 tons of total lift it's
designed to cruise at maximum speed of
60 knots
it could probably go over 2 000 nautical
miles in one leg
our mission is to expand and complement
existing humanitarian relief using
lighter than air technology and at the
same time reduce the carbon footprint of
Aviation
rather amazingly some of the first
airships ever made lived right here in
this hangar
almost a hundred years ago the Navy
began building airships in Ohio so they
could be flown to California
the Navy saw these craft is key to
Gathering intelligence and Performing
reconnaissance
as the Glory Days of airships you've
shown me some of these slides just here
in Silicon valleys there were times when
the sky was like filled with airships
and and then they were doing amazing
things I mean there's one that was
almost like an aircraft carrier this was
actually in 1932 and 33 there was a hook
on the Airship and by planes were
carried inside the Airship okay they
were refueled
then of course airships had some very
bad PR
planes came along
and people lost interest in these
Majestic beasts large airships
disappeared in 1939 so like everything
people might think of those are all
blimps and the difference being a blimp
just has no rigid structure right this
is a rigid Airship with a skeleton and
so the skeleton defines the shape
and Al thinks he can bring these sexy
hard-bodied airships back
this time filled with nice non-flammable
helium so you've got this wonderful
history and you're like making it all
happen again right right back to the
future
can we do the horn
sure
I think anyone I've ever heard anyone
use it before
this is Carl tossick he's a mechanical
engineer I've known for years who really
gets around Silicon Valley
I asked him to give me The Grand Tour
a lot of scaffolding yeah it's
incredible
at first glance it appears almost
nothing has changed in a hundred years
but really this thing is a mix of the
super old and the super new
so this is one of 12 of the electric
motors that Propel the ship okay and
it's uh you can see it's Motors mounted
on a pylon which can rotate so think of
this Airship as a giant quadcopter all
these are thrust vectored they can be
pointed in order to lift the ship
straight up or move laterally and then
hear this outer material is a is kind of
leveraged from racing sailboats okay
this is how it's laced on and this is a
kind of an anachronism from the way
airships were built 100 years ago
there's 40 000 of these lacing tabs each
one is laced by hand she's
[Applause]
the Pathfinder one skeleton is made of
carbon fiber making it lighter and
stronger than past airships the ship
will run on diesel to start but LTA
hopes to switch to either solar or some
form of hydrogen power in the future
overall the Airship will be much slower
than a plane but at least the passengers
will feel virtuous about their carbon
footprint
I've never been in a gondola
dying to seat about 10 people it's it's
used commercially for sightseeing by the
Zeppelin company on their NT airships
and so if you're doing like a
two three day Journey from London to New
York so you're just you're hanging out
in here in this space
admittedly for a futuristic Airship this
is an underwhelming interior but this
ship is just an experimental vehicle the
first of its kind and not for the public
and the company has bigger things in
mind than just leisurely Sky cruises I
think you guys are most interested in
kind of disaster scenarios I mean that's
the heart of why you're making this
thing right when you arrive at a
disaster site you often show up and the
place is wrecked and so the port may not
be working
you then have to get your supplies to
where the disaster is and typically you
know the roads are gone
helicopters are really expensive to
operate they have limited range and
limited capacity to liftings so that's
where an Airship can also help and it's
the cargo right I mean they can carry a
significant amount of stuff right we've
studied airships that could carry up to
200 tons of cargo
our approach is scalable to build larger
airships that could carry even more
[Music]
of riding lighter than air is on the
cusp of revealing this beauty to the
world
but many potential Kinks remain
the market for slow weather dependent
Airship travel may not be enormous and
the cargo applications our favors are a
bit further out
but if the site of this white whale
doesn't move you frankly I'm not sure
why you're watching my show Al promised
my two kids one of the first first rides
it'll be a great ride
your kids though flight test Engineers
just keep them safe
[Music]